how are you doing sir
oh dude it's just 20 20 up in this [ __ ]
all over it
just 20 20 everywhere got it uh i really
do have a bunch of questions
so let's see what we can do um so i'm
going to start with the most important
question which is always the way i want
to start every interview off
um will the character of gabriel edwards
be making an appearance on the gossip
girl reboot
uh if that happens i will literally
eat your shoe
i'm not even joking got it okay uh
well i mean that's an early work for you
um you know yeah
listen i mean you know pays the bills
gets you experience
you got to start somewhere you know 100
percent
got my ass to new york you know that's
fine that's fine i got to work in new
york for a bit
exactly um the next most important
question and i actually is the real
question
what do you and i have to do to get tom
ford to make more movies
dude i know i know you know what it's so
funny
he's such a creative genius
uh in every single aspect that he
applies his creativity but the problem
with tom ford is
his bandwidth of creativity is so large
that he has so much [ __ ] he can be a
genius on
so getting him to sit down and focus on
any one of them is probably really tough
i'm sure the people in the cologne line
and i mean you've smelled his colognes
are like
hey man we'd love more work over here
and the people in the clothes and you've
seen his clothes they're like hey but we
need your attention too
everybody wants some attention i think
he's made two films and they're both
fantastic
they're both incredible i mean the fact
single man was like his
uh first film ever and it was actually a
piece of art i mean it's just incredible
no we're on the same page this is
actually a sincere question that has
been very
very sincere oh no i don't know but if
you figure it out let me know what i can
do to help
got it uh what tv series would you love
to guest star on
ooh uh dude you know what i've
i've been getting into tv shows that i
had missed that i didn't see
because i was too busy or whatever and
now because of this like i have more
time
uh i just watched an episode of
workaholics last night where ben stiller
was the guest star i'm not even joking
and i was like
that's ben stiller and he and then ben
stiller got into a front yard
wrestling match with these guys uh and
beat the [ __ ] out of them on the show
and i was like this looks amazing like
workaholics is the show that i'm into
right now i'm like
i'm just about to finish workaholics and
i'm so bummed because i feel like i'm
gonna lose three buddies
what movie do you think you've seen the
most
it would either be the first matrix
cool hand luke or fight club
probably in that order do you remember
your first
movie or tv show crush
first movie or tv show crush
dude do you remember i was thinking
about this show the other day
uh do you remember a show that was set
in santa monica
about bike police on the ocean like on
on the boardwalk
this is how long ago this was it was on
usa network back when that was like a
thing
i should know this but i don't i don't
know the name i don't remember the name
either but there was like a blonde chick
on there who rode a bicycle and i think
i was like 13
and going through puberty and i was like
yep this is all this is it for me
this is what you're like yeah no i i
completely understand that
um pacific blue pacific blue someone
just jumped in do you see it down there
thank you kyle
pacific blue oh my god i've been trying
to remember the name of that show for
probably four years and i don't know how
many times i typed
bike police santa monica tv show and
like he couldn't get anything pacific
blue okay
back to the important things people ask
you this all the time and i've asked you
this all the time and i'm still going to
ask you this
um obviously i love man from uncle and
just like everybody else who's seen it
um so what do we need to do to get more
and and now here's my pitch if someone
were to write some
fan fiction or like some quasi-animated
thing
would would you be willing to voice it
and then we could just try to ask henry
to do it too
i mean it i would do another man from
uncle in a heartbeat like
in a heartbeat uh if someone wrote a
really good piece of fanfic
i'd narrate it uh if someone wrote an
extremely good piece of fanfic
i would make sure it got to [ __ ] guy
and lionel and be like you guys need to
read this
and then give this person co-writing
credit because let's just get this movie
made let's just do this
look i'm all in on that i think that
movie is criminally underrated
and that's why i keep on bringing it up
because people need to watch it
yeah i mean it was so much fun to make
honestly it's one of the movies
i mean a part obviously from like call
me by your name it's one of the movies
that i get the most messages about
people just being like i want another
one of those what do we do no 100
speaking of call me by your name the
best film of that year uh
obviously like everyone i want to get a
sequel to it
and i know you guys want to make one but
i also think that one of the things
about that movie is you really need like
years to pass in real life to almost
make the movie
the sequel resonate because you need to
have
like lines in your face like i'm getting
there
i get in there steve i'm aging like milk
in a warm car buddy
come on i haven't noticed that if i can
get all these grays in there
i i haven't noticed that but do you but
do you agree with that that like
even though everyone's talking about it
i think it needs like 10 years before
you know it needs room to breathe too i
mean so many people
are emotionally invested in the first
call me by your name that
if you release a second one now no
matter what i feel like you're just
setting yourself up for failure
uh if you give us time and you know i
mean like the like the story is supposed
to happen if you give us that time
and then we can come back you know when
i'm in my 40s
you know and timmy's 23
you know then we could do it again then
you know right no i just think it's
important people talk about that that
it's just not going to work if you do it
like
next year 100 agree agree i completely
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you today uh what you so you're
presented with this either ben
calls you someone's handing you a script
are you at first like
wait you want to redo hitchcock what
wait what
that was exactly my reaction and ben was
like yeah
and i was like okay cool
like you know you're the director you're
the boss if you feel good about it i
feel good about it
how would you compare this one to the
hitchcock version
uh for fans that maybe have seen the
original this is exactly how i would put
it uh
the hitchcock version was the fastest
car
in 1940. that's the year it came out it
was the fastest car it won best picture
like literally the fastest car in this
analogy
if you made exactly that same car now or
tried to replicate that
car now it would be atrocious it
wouldn't have power steering it wouldn't
have power brakes it wouldn't have seat
belts it wouldn't have anything that
modern cars are required to have just so
that we don't die
right and also it wouldn't drive as well
i think if you go back and watch the
hitchcock film
for 1940 it is an incredible piece of
art
but personally i think it aged
a little less gracefully than a lot of
hitchcock's other work
i mean rear window is pressing as buck
uh rope uh psycho birds like
all those things you know then you go
back and you watch rebecca and it looks
like a set
crazy intense lighting very kind of
polarized light
and dark um and
you know i i think that what ben wanted
to do was instead of saying we're
remaking hitchcock
we did exactly what hitchcock did which
is we took the book
and we adapted the book we weren't
thinking about hitchcock's version we
weren't trying to emulate anything that
hitchcock did
we were going back to the original
source material just like hitchcock did
and he made changes
in the original source material he
changed the way rebecca died he changed
he
changed some big things in the movie and
we wanted to stay more
true to the original source material uh
and that's what we did
as i was watching it you guys had a lot
of like
long singular takes um and so and it
felt
like you guys were going for this like
1940s kind of
feel um or just like a different kind of
feel
can you talk when you're as an actor
when you're on set how cognizant
are you of the choices that the director
is making with the lens
and with the shots and how much are you
sort of like
just focused on your um you know your
performance
i mean i guess it depends on the actor
really it's probably pretty subjective
i i'm i'm like i like to be hyper aware
of those kinds of things like i want to
know
exactly what lens you put on there i
want to know why i want to know what
camera movement you're doing
i want to know everything because i want
to i want to learn how to do that
like i i would like to direct films one
day so for me it's very important to
learn
you know what a 75 millimeter lens looks
like
you know through a camera i i want to
know these things so when he says oh no
we've got it we've got a 50 on there i
go oh okay so then
so then your frame should be about right
here and i'll go yeah and i go okay cool
so then i'll make sure to hold the thing
here and i'll do this and blah blah
you know who i learned that from uh
johnny depp was the first person i ever
saw do this and it blew me away
we were standing in front of the camera
and he had like something that he was
supposed to hold in his hand
and we were just about to roll and he
stops and he looks at the camera
operator this guy named martin and he
goes martin what what what lens he won
and martin goes ah it's uh it's a 75
john
and he goes okay well then i'll hold it
right here and he literally brought it
up to exactly the perfect place in frame
without
looking at a monitor like it wasn't like
he was looking at the thing and went
okay i'll bring it right there it's like
he literally said that's a 75
okay there that's where it'll go and it
was the perfect spot and i just remember
being blown away just being like this
guy this guy knows and [ __ ] man
and i'd rather be that guy so but then
again there's some actors who don't want
to think about that
like they don't want to be thinking
about the camera at all they don't want
to be thinking about tech stuff they
just want to be focused on what they're
doing
and that works too if you get to direct
a movie what is the
genre you want to play in i don't know
because like genre
is pretty fluid right like you know i
mean this
this movie just rebecca it feels like
it's got like three different genres
that are all kind of like mingling
together
you know in it inside like sort of like
the holistic picture
so for me it's more about i love the
idea of like uh
of a good like hero's journey in the
joseph campbell sense you know whether
it's reluctant hero
or like a failed journey or what but
like i just i like the idea of
classic storytelling uh and so it would
probably be something
in that thing are you close to directing
or is it something that like you're
still building towards
i'm probably closer than i would like to
admit but like i'm still
it's a big step and i still you know
it's like indiana jones with that big
like
leap of faith right where he's got to
cross that gorge and
he doesn't see the [ __ ] bridge there
that's kind of where i'm at where it's
like look at this point like i've been
on sets
for you know 15 years i've been paying
attention to everything directors do and
bothering the [ __ ] out of dps for 15
years just being like why that light why
this why that why that
so i mean i feel like i've accumulated
the knowledge it's just about having the
having the confidence to go yeah you
know what let's just do it [ __ ] it why
not
i'm a big fan of sam esmell um
and so what's the status of gas lit uh
we're we're supposed to go next year
so what can you tell people about it
well i play john dean
and it's the story of the watergate
standard uh
it's the story of corrupt politicians
it's the story
of uh lying to the public it's the story
about getting caught it's a story about
accountability it's a story about all of
this and it'll have
uh sean penn and julia roberts in it so
what's not to love
yeah no actors i know i know yeah
me steadily bringing up the rear on that
one i don't think that's true
actually uh uh i like the humbleness but
uh uh
you you have game right um right so i
listen i think one of the most important
things going on right now is dealing
with the opioid
epidemic i think that it is a massive
problem that is
under even though we talk about it it's
still underserved
you know it's still a huge issue uh you
have a
movie coming out called dreamland which
deals with that head-on
um what was it about that project that
said i want to do this and
and talk a little bit about it well you
know nick jorecki who directed it
uh he he's a friend of mine we've known
each other for a long time and he came
to me he said hey man listen i've
i'm i've got this movie uh it's about
the opioid crisis
and i've i've almost lost multiple
friends
to opioid addictions whether it be you
know heroin or pills or
a mixture of both um and it is
it is a massive epidemic that we are
dealing with in america that
because pharmaceutical medications make
so much money
not only for the pharmaceutical
companies but also for
lobbyists also for politicians also for
everyone
we turn a blind eye to this i mean the
amount of people who die from opioid
addictions
in america is staggering um and also i
read the script and i thought this is
really good and this is really
interesting and it's really highlighting
that this doesn't just affect you know
this affects everyone there's there's no
one safe
from opioid addiction especially in
america where they're so quick to
prescribe pills and
and also with how easy it is and also
with with fentanyl the fact that we've
invented this [ __ ]
poison called fentanyl that's like a
hundred times stronger than morphine
and just the littlest tiny sprinkle of
it and you'll overdose
and you know and this the movie is about
a drug ring in canada
that is getting the uh ingredients for
fentanyl sent in from china
processing it and then shipping the
pills down into america and
this is what's happening this this
happens all the time you know i mean
so um we wanted to make a film about it
and show the sort of like the stark
reality of it
i could keep on going on that but i also
want to talk about taika's new movie uh
next goal wins which is obviously we're
huge
taika fans i know you are too yeah this
is this is a completely different movie
than i think people are expecting
um can you tell people what it's about
and also what was it like
having him on set directing um i mean
he's
so talented so talented i mean he's he's
he's
he's phenomenally talented he's almost
too talented for his own good
uh but he it's the story of
a coach played by play hilariously and
perfectly by michael fassbender
uh who goes to kind of like as a
dead-end
job just to kind of get rid of him they
send him down to american samoa to go
coach a soccer team there and it's about
what happens to this coach when he goes
down to samoa to coach a soccer team
um it's it's hilarious and it's fun and
it's heartfelt and there are things in
it that are really touching
and like like all of tychus films i mean
like
hunt for the wilder people like you know
i mean that that movie is
funny and touching and you'll cry and
laugh in the same film and like that's
very taika you know i mean when he wants
to do that that's what he's gonna do
uh having him on set is the best you
know when he's when he's not sleeping
that is um but uh uh
actually his his napping thing is is
also
very impressive he's got this thing
where he'll go okay set up this camera
over there send it back over there set
up that over there how long will that be
and they'll be like uh that'll be about
three minutes and he'll go
great and then he'll be
out and then two minutes and 55 seconds
later he'll go
okay are the cameras ready he was like
what was that
like holy [ __ ] man um but he also
his brain works better than everyone
else's
so when the whole point of the script or
i'm sorry when the whole point of the
film was
a lot of improvisation he would be there
with me okay now
go go down that line let's not talk
about this okay now talk about that now
say this now say that you know i mean
he's right there
helping you and coaching you through
this whole thing and it just makes you
feel really safe and really protected
and uh yeah i mean he's a lot of fun to
work with
on that note i need to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on everything
pleasure to see you uh and i'm sure i'll
talk to you soon all right steven good
to see you my man